oh my gosh have you ever seen anything
so wonderful
we've watched the disney princesses so
many times
their voices are forever fixed in our
minds but how much do we really know
about the real voices behind the royal
squad
i want to thank you for stopping that
man ming now wen
voices mulan across all of her animated
appearances
since the 1998 movie that includes the
2004 direct to video sequel
and mulan's appearance in the 2018 movie
ralph breaks the internet
the actress was born in 1963 so she
would have been around 35 years old when
the original disney animation was
released
that's more than double the character's
age as mulan was just
16 in her first film but were most
excited to spill the tea
about ming na's voice work as mulan on
sophia the first in 2014.
did you watch the disney junior show
growing up then you'll love this piece
of insider info
ming na's daughter michaela z provided
the voice of princess june on the show
how fun is that mingna went on to voice
the character
vega on sophia the first two although
ming na
provided mulan's speaking voice it was
actually leia salonga who provided
mulan's singing voice and her animated
appearances
leia also provided jasmine's singing
voice in the 1992 movie aladdin
the singer explained that the director
needed her to show
emotion in her voice as they would
animate to that
so leia said i just try to sound happy
as for jasmine's speaking voice that
came courtesy of linda larkin
is it that obvious she went on to
provide the princess's voice in her
subsequent animated appearances
that includes the sequels the tv series
sofia the first
and ralph breaks the internet in 2019
linda dished to the today show that her
favorite jasmine line
which sums up the whole experience is
it's all so magical
of course robin william is the most
famous voice actor in aladdin
voicing the part of the genie
do you think i'm odd paige o'hara voiced
belle
in the 1991 movie beauty and the beast
and it's not just her voice that was a
big part of belle's personality
it was also her mannerisms paige
explained that she had long brown hair
at the time
and she always had bangs in her eyes
when i was recording
i kept pushing it away and the next
thing i knew they've animated it
paige was born in 1956 so she was around
35 years old when the film came out
belle was half that age at just 17 but
paige thought
belle was just like her paige went on to
voice belle
in later animated appearances including
ralph breaks the internet
paige is one of a few disney princess
voices that make a cameo in the 2007
movie enchanted
you monster paige o'haras bff
jody benson also has a cameo in
enchanted
she plays secretary sam who works next
to an aquarium fish tank
that's a total easter egg because jody
is
of course best known for voicing ariel
in the little mermaid
jody's continued to voice ariel since
the 1989 movie
in sequels and ralph breaks the internet
jody also provided ariel's singing voice
and in 2019 jody recreated that classic
song for the today show
she got to voice ariel and another
character in sofia the first
leader of the mermaids queen emeline
she's also voiced
other animated characters like barbie in
the toy story franchise
and the title role in the 1994 movie
thumbelina she even voiced lady in the
2001
lady in the [ __ ] direct-to-video sequel
pat carroll
who voiced ursula also voiced old lady
crowley
entangled the series my name is
pocahontas pocahontas is another
character that had a different voice
actor for her speaking
and singing voices irene beddard did the
dialogue
while judy kuhn performed songs like
colors of the wind
irene went on to voice pocahontas and
other animated appearances
like the direct-to-video sequel and
ralph breaks the internet
but here's a little-known fact you might
recognize her as
madam president in jay-z's 2018 music
video
family feud the most famous actors
behind the voices in the 1995 animated
feature however
are the two male characters the legend
that is
mel gibson voice john smith and batman
himself
christian bale voice thomas well he's
tall and handsome and
and so romantic if you think these
movies from the 80s and 90s feel like
a lifetime ago then sleeping beauty
feels like ancient history
we're going right back to 1959
the voice behind aurora mary costa
turned
90 in 2020 after working on sleeping
beauty
she went on to have a long career
performing in operas
and she's still been acting in her late
80s
mary also provided aurora's singing
voice as well as her speaking voice
in an interview she revealed how walt
disney himself had said to her
i want you to paint with your voice
however
mary didn't reprise her voice role as
aurora for sophia the first
or ralph breaks the internet kate
higgins took on that job instead
eleanor oddly voiced maleficent she also
provided the voice for lady tremaine in
cinderella
because if you tell a wish it won't come
true
it was thanks to eileen wood's singing
voice that she got the job of voicing
cinderella in the 1950 movie she
revealed in an interview in 1995
that her songwriter friends asked her to
record vocals for their demos
they came to me to record their songs to
present to mr disney
and she didn't know she would even be
considered for the role
but when walt heard eileen's vocals he
decided
then and there that she was the voice of
cinderella
it's incredibly rare for the person who
recorded the demo to actually get the
part
eileen also revealed that she took her
three-year-old daughter
stephanie to the premiere and when the
movie came on the little girl
shouted out my mommy is cinderella
two old ladies sitting behind them said
isn't that sweet
she thinks her mother is cinderella
little did they know
she'd been honored with a disney legend
award in 2003.
jennifer hale took on voice duties for
ralph breaks the internet oh how silly
of me
i'm snow white finishing at the
beginning with the very first disney
princess
snow white adriana castelotti was chosen
as her voice at just 18 years old
which is totally fitting she's one of
the youngest princess voice actors and
snow white is the youngest disney
princess
at just 14 years old adriana's mom
dad and sister all sang too in fact
it's thanks to her father that adriana
got the part
her dad taught music and walt's rep
called him to ask if any students might
be suitable for the role
but adriana was listening in on the
extension line
and showcased her talent right there and
then i said
papa how about me although adriana
performed a short line in the wizard of
oz
it's a wonderful life and a few operatic
roles she couldn't continue to showcase
her singing
in movies disney wanted her voice to be
linked to snow white
and nothing else and a strict contract
kept it that way
her dedication to the part was honored
with a disney legend award in 1994
three years before she passed away at
the age of 80.
it was down to pamela ribbon to voice
snow white and ralph breaks the internet
oh yes i like to stare at a wishing well
which disney princess's voice is your
favorite and which behind the scenes
secret surprised you the most
sound off in the comments section below
and give this video a big
thumbs up if you love the disney
princesses as much as we do
thanks for watching